NICOLA MARZARI:
OK, good morning.
And welcome to lecture 6.
We're still working on
electronic structure methods.
And today in particular, we'll
finish up our introduction
of the Hartree-Fock methods,
if you want the cornerstone
of quantum chemistry.
Really developed
in the late '20s,
we have Douglas Hartree
here from the University
of Cambridge and Fock, I
think, from the University
of St. Petersburg.
And then we'll also go into
Density-Functional theory that,
in many ways, is a much
more recent approach.
The theory itself was
developed in the '60s
by Walter Kohn in collaboration
with Pierre Hohenberg
and in collaboration
with Lu Sham.
But really, I would say
it's only in the mid '70s
and then really in
the mid '80s that it
started to take off as
actually a practical approach
to study the electronic
structure, especially
of solids, and has become very
popular, popular to the point
that the Nobel Prize
for chemistry in '98
was given to Walter Kohn for
DFT and John Pople, a quantum
chemist, for the development
of quantum chemistry methods.
Let me remind you before we go
on into the lecture of the two
main conclusions of last class.
The first one was the
appropriate matrix formulation
of the Schrodinger
equation that is something
that is very powerful
and very useful
when we actually need
to solve a differential
equation on a computer.
And the hypothesis there was
that we had chosen a basis set
that I indicate here with phi.
That would be the basis set in
which I would expand my ground
stateway function.
And so once the
basis set is chosen--
it could be sines and cosines
with different wavelengths.
It could be localized wave
functions like Gaussians.
It could be just points
on a discrete grid.
But once my basis set is
chosen, and once I know what is
my electronic structure
problem-- that is,
once I know what is the
potential in my Hamiltonian
operator--
this here, these integrals,
are just numbers.
So solving the Schrodinger
equation-- that is,
finding the key E eigenvalues
and the corresponding
eigenvectors--
is nothing else than solving
this linear algebra problem
where, again, these coefficients
here form a vector that really
gives me what are the terms
in the expansion of my wave
function, in terms
of orthonormal basis.
And so linear algebra problems,
we have a matrix here.
And it will have, if it's
an order n matrix, n values
for which the determinant is 0.
And those are the
eigenvalues for which
we can find the solution.
So this is important not
only in electronic structure,
but in a lot of applied
computational approaches.
And the other very
useful principle here
that I have listed is the
variational principle.
That is, again, it is possible
to define a functional--
that is, if you
want an algorithm--
that takes as input
a generic function
and gives us output, a number.
And the functional
that we use is
the functional that
I've written here
with the integral expectation
value of the Hamiltonian
on an arbitrary wave
function divided by basically
a normalization term.
And it can be proven--
and it was given
to us an exercise--
that this quantity
is always greater
or equal than the ground state.
And this is very
powerful because, if we
have no idea on what the
solution for our ground state
problem is, well, we
can just try out a few.
And our best
solution-- although,
we will never know if it's
the exact one or not--
will be the one that gives
the lowest expectation value
for this term.
And here is an example
on how we could actually
go on and try to solve a very
simple problem that is finding
the eigenstates and eigenvalues
for a hydrogen atom using
the variational principle.
And instead of trying actually
different wave functions
at a time, what we can do
that is very meaningful
is choose a parametric
format for the wave function.
So you see, I'm writing
here a generic wave function
that decays as an exponential
as a function of the r distance
from the nucleus from the
center of the electron.
So if you wanted
this parameter here,
alpha determines how steep
the decay of this wave
function here.
So by writing it
in this way, I'm
not considering any more
just one way function.
But I am considering an
entire family of functions
with different decays.
And so what I can do is try
this family of wave functions.
And so what I would do
is stick this expression
in this expectation value.
And then actually,
the constant, C,
is what we call a
normalization constant.
It always cancels out, you
see, from the integral below
and the integral above.
This C squared
would just go away.
And so overall, the variational
principle and expectation value
is a parametric
function of alpha.
And the optimal alpha
will be the alpha
that gives me the minimum
value for this number.
Again, we can't go
below the ground state
for this expectation value.
So the lower that we
can go, the better.
And if we use this particular
choice of wave function--
and this is, again, a very
simple analysis problem
that you could actually
work out by yourself.
I've actually written here all
the terms of the normalization
integral.
What is its value as a function
of this parameter once you
do it properly in
spherical coordinates,
considering that this is
really the radial distance,
and this is the expectation
value of the kinetic energy,
value of-- you see minus 1
over r.
That is the potential
for the electron
in the field of a proton.
And if you minimize this
expression-- very easy--
what you obtain is
alpha equal to 1.
So the optimal solution
is then alpha equal to 1.
It turns out that, by solving
directly the differential
equation, the
Schrodinger equation,
we actually know that this
exponential of minus r
is actually the exact solution.
And so what happens,
in this case,
is that this parametric
family of wave functions
is the right form.
That is, it contains actually
the exact the ground state
among all its possible forms.
And that exact ground
state is reached
when alpha is equal to 1.
And the variational principle
will give us alpha equal to 1
without having any
need of solving
the very complex radial
Schrodinger equation that I've
shown at a certain point
in the class on Tuesday
where we really need to solve
for the spherical harmonics
and find the Legendre
polynomial, Laguerre terms
in the radial part,
and so on and so forth.
So this becomes very simple.
And for this reason, the
variational principle
is very powerful.
And we'll actually see
how Hartree and Fock use
that to find out a way to tackle
the problem of many electrons
interacting because, up to now,
we have really only thought
of the problem of one
electron in a potential.
But the problem of many
interacting electrons
increases its
complexity very quickly.
So I'm just showing here what
would be, say, the Schrodinger
equation for a two-electron
atom, say something typically
like the atom of helium.
You have a nucleus that
has really two protons.
And then you have two
electrons around the nucleus,
going around.
And so what is the Hamiltonian,
the quantum mechanical
Hamiltonian for this problem?
Well, what we have is the
kinetic energy terms here.
So we have a Laplacian that is
a second derivative in space
for each one of the coordinates.
So you see this is
the wave function.
The wave function
is an amplitude
that is a function of the
combined position of r1
describing the first
electron and r2 describing
the second electron.
So you have these two
second derivatives.
And then there is
the term that deals
with the attraction
between electron 1,
say this electron
here, and the nucleus.
We have an attraction term
here, Coulombic attraction,
that goes basically as 2/r or as
Z/r if we think of the nucleus
as having charge Z. And so
there is attraction here
of the first electron
to the nucleus
and then attraction of the
second electron to the nucleus.
And then the last term is
actually a repulsive term--
so there should be
actually a plus sign here--
between the two electrons.
And so you see it depends--
again, Coulombic comparison
between the electrons--
on the distance between r1 and
r2, the instantaneous position.
So you see, this is how
the Hamiltonian becomes,
in the case of an atom that has
two electrons and everything
here, the final generalization
still for one atom
but with many electrons.
So in the case where,
again, you have
a nucleus with many
electrons orbiting around,
what you will have
is a wave function
that is a combined amplitude of
n different spatial variables.
So if we have, say, an atom
like iron that has 26 electrons,
well, that wave function
is a combined amplitude
of 78 coordinates.
And the Hamiltonian
operator, again,
is our second derivative
for each electron in there
as an attractive term
for each electron that
is attracted to the nucleus that
now has a charge Z equal to 26.
And then each electron-- so this
sum i goes over each electron.
Each electron will be
repelling each other electron.
So there is an overall
repulsive term.
And we actually call
this term here--
this is the difficult term.
We call this term
here a two-body term
because it depends on the
simultaneous possession of two
electrons.
Well, if you want,
the first the terms
here are called one-body
terms because they act only
on one electron
at a time, quantum
kinetic energy and attraction.
And truly, this
Schrodinger equation
becomes overly complex
already by the time
when we have two electrons.
So we can't solve analytically
even the helium atom, OK?
We can solve everything
about the hydrogen atom.
And we can solve the
Schrodinger equation
for a number of very
simple problems.
But already, for the helium
atom, we can't do that.
And so in the '40s
and '50s, people
developed variational
approaches.
They were making an uncertain
hypothesis on this wave
function, expanding
this wave function
in a series of other functions,
depending parametrically
on a number of coefficients--
2, 3, 5, 8, 200 coefficients.
And the more coefficients
there were, the more flexible
that wave function was.
And so systematically, by adding
more and more flexibility,
you could go lower and lower.
And hopefully, you
were converging.
And say for something
like the helium atom,
well, the total energy of two
electrons in the helium atom
is something like
5.8, 5.8 Rydbergs.
And you could get
very, very close,
down to a fraction of
hundreds of electron volts
just by 3 or 5 parameters.
But then as you go to
more and more electrons,
the problem really has a
complexity that explodes.
And in all of this,
I want to remind you,
I'm not using any more the
international system of units.
So I'm not using
meters and seconds.
But I'm using what are
called atomic units.
And there is a handout on your
Stellar web page reminding
that the unit of energy is
what we call the Hartree that
corresponds to another set
of unit that are often used.
Say a Hartree
corresponds to Rydberg.
And the Rydberg is
13.6 electron volts.
And electron volt is the
energy of an electron that
feels a potential
difference of 1 volt.
And 1 electron volt
is often considered
23.5 kilocalories per mole.
In the electronic
structure literature,
you'll see all these numbers.
Often, chemists use the
kilocalorie per mole unit.
Physicists tend to use
the electron volts.
And again, I remind you that
the average kinetic energy
of an atom at room temperature
is 0.04 electron volts.
And the binding of water
dimer is 0.29 electron volts.
So the electron volts
is really the order
of magnitude of the binding
of weakly attached molecules.
OK.
So now, the problem--
and that's where the Hartree
and Hartree-Fock solution become
important--
is to deal with a
realistic system.
That is, we need to
deal with molecules
or we need to deal with solids.
So we need to
deal, in principle,
with a Schrodinger equation in
which we have a lot of nuclei.
I'm denoting here with capital
R the position of the nuclei.
Again, if you want
to find out what
is the structure of benzene,
if you want to find out
what is the electron
structure of silicon,
you need to keep in mind
that, say for benzene, you
will have six Coulombic
attractive centers that
are the six carbon
nuclei in a ring
and also the six
1/r protons around.
So the position of
those nuclei determines
what is the potential
acting on your electrons.
So in principle, the
Schrodinger equation
will be something like
I've written here.
But we can make this
fundamental simplification
that will always be the case
for the classes that follow.
That is, we never treat the
nuclei as quantum particles,
OK?
In principle, also the
nuclei are quantum particles.
So they would have
their own wavelength.
They come in as variables
into the wave function.
And you would need to
calculate, say, things
like the quantum kinetic
energy of the nucleus.
That is the Laplacian,
the second derivative
of the overall wave
function with respect
to the nuclear coordinates.
In practice, remember
the Bernoulli relation.
The nuclei are so heavy that
their wavelength is very, very
small.
So we can truly treat them
as classical particles.
And the electrons are so
much faster than the nuclei
that even if the nuclei move,
the electrons can always,
much faster than the
nuclei, follow this movement
and reorganize themselves as
to be getting the lowest energy
state possible.
Basically, you have to imagine
this picture of the molecule
vibrating at room temperature.
And the nucleus then will
have a kinetic energy.
All the mass of the
molecule is in the nuclei.
So all the effects of
temperature, if you want,
are in the vibration
of the nuclei.
But these vibrations are
very slow from the point
of view of the electrons.
So the electrons see that
the nucleus is slowly moving
and rearrange themselves as
to being in the ground state
for that instantaneous
configuration of the nuclei.
Obviously, if the nucleus
starts moving very, very
fast by any chance, well, then
the electrons can't do this.
They can't follow any more.
And so if you
want, you can start
having electronic excitation.
That is the electrons
are not anymore
on the lowest energy state
possible for that given
configuration.
That doesn't really
happen, especially
if we are just considering
a molecule a solid at room
temperature.
But it could happen, say, if we
have an external potential that
changes very fast.
If we shine a laser
light on a molecule,
then light is nothing less
than a electromagnetic field.
And laser light will
typically have a frequency
that is fast and comparable to
the frequency of the electrons.
And so all these adiabatic
approximations break down.
And lo and behold, we can
actually excite with the laser
the electron in a
higher energy state.
But for what you are
seeing in this class,
we'll always think of the
electrons in a ground state.
That this is what people
call often the adiabatic
or the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
These two terms, in most cases,
are used in the same way.
Although, chemists tend to make
a subtle distinction about what
adiabatic means and
Born-Oppenheimer means.
And adiabatic really
refers to the coupling
between the different potential
surfaces for the electrons,
depending on the
velocity of the nuclei.
And Born-Oppenheimer
implies that there
is no influence of the
ionic motion of one
single electronic surface.
But I mean, this is
fairly technical.
Just remember that sometimes
these two terms actually mean
something very different
and very specific.
OK.
So this has now become our
most general expression
for the Hamiltonian and also for
the energy of a set of nuclei
and a set of electrons.
That is really our picture
of a molecule or a solid.
And again, we will have
the nuclei generating
Coulombic attractive potentials
in every position where
they are.
So there is what we call
an electron nucleus term.
That is an attractive
term in which
we have a sum over
each and every electron
because each and every electron
feels the potential of all
the nuclei.
And the sum of all the nuclei
refers to a sum of Z/r terms.
So in whole space, wherever
there is a nucleus,
there is a 1/r term.
And this sum over nuclei
is the overall potential
for the electronic system.
And each electron
feels this potential.
And this is the fundamental
attractive term.
So electrons are
attracted to the nuclei.
But also, electrons
repel each other.
And this is the other term.
So you see each
and every electron
has a charge 1 in
atomic units and has
a Coulombic repulsion with
each and every other electron.
And then, of course,
for each electron,
we have the quantum
kinetic energy here.
And so I listed here in the
Hamiltonian all these terms.
We have the quantum
kinetic energy here.
We have the
electron-electron repulsion.
And we have the
electron-nucleus attraction.
And then there is
a last term that
is truly a classical
term because it
involves only the nuclei.
And so it's a
repulsive term that is
the nucleus-nucleus repulsion.
So if you want to think for a
moment of a hydrogen molecule,
say, what you would there is
a nucleus, another nucleus,
and then a wave function of
all the electrons around.
And there is a classic term that
is the electrostatic repulsion
between the two nuclei.
And there is a quantum term of
repulsion between the electrons
and an attraction between
the electron and the nuclei.
And basically, all these
electrostatic terms--
nucleus-nucleus,
electron-nucleus,
and electron-electron--
almost balance themselves.
Each and every
one is very large.
But then the combination
of these three almost
cancels itself out.
And that's why actually the
binding energy of a molecule
is much, much smaller than
any of the energy, say,
of two charges at that
distance repelling each other
or even just the energy
of a core electron
very close to its nucleus.
And that's why also electronic
structure calculations are
very delicate because
what you need to find out
is a total energy that is
the combination of terms that
largely cancel each other out.
And so you need to be
very accurate in order
to actually decide if something
like a hydrogen molecule
binds together or breaks apart.
OK.
Now, this is truly
a problem of greater
computational complexity.
And as I said over
and over again,
we can't really deal,
even computationally,
with an object that has all the
information content of a wave
function.
So let me actually
go through this
into the next slide, in which
I've written out explicitly
the example of the iron atom.
So that has, again,
26 electrons.
So the electromagnetic
wave function
will in itself
have 78 variables.
And if you think
about how many numbers
do we need to store this object
with any kind of precision,
well, suppose that we even limit
ourselves to a very, very core
sampling, only say 10 values
around either nucleus.
Well, even to give
this wave function,
to give this amplitude with
this very core sampling,
we would need 10
to the 78 numbers.
So basically, there is no
way we can numerically deal
with the complexity
of the wave function.
And this is where the power
of the variational principle
and the ideas of
Hartree-Fock came together.
And we'll first discuss
the first idea of Hartree
in dealing with this problem.
Remember, what we have is a
set of interacting electrons.
And I like to compare each
one of you to an electron.
So what you need
to think, and what
the complexity of
this problem is,
is that at every instant
in time each one of you
is interacting or actually
repelling with each one else.
So this is the complexity
of a many-body problem.
In order to understand
what's happening,
each thing needs to know
what everyone else is doing.
And Hartree
introduced the concept
of independent particles
and effective potential.
This is something
that comes over not
only in electronic
structure, but it comes over
in a lot of problems
where we actually
need to deal with a very large
number of interacting elements
and interacting particles.
And the general idea is that
we can approximate and try
to solve this problem
by not considering what
each electron instantly does.
But we can solve the
problem by treating
what one electron would
do in a field that,
on average, represents what
all the other electrons would
be doing.
So if we want to think,
say, what I would be doing--
I shouldn't try to find the
solution that instantaneously
knows about what each and
everyone else is doing.
But I could try to find a
solution for myself interacting
electrostatically with the
average charge distribution
that everyone else does.
So instead of
having to know what
is the instantaneous
position of all
the other interacting
electrons, I
could make an approximation
that I could actually really
just try to deal with
the way I interact
with an average distribution
of everyone else.
So this is, if you want,
the concept of mean field
or effective potential.
We are averaging over
all the variables.
And there is actually
a mathematical way
to do this that I'll
introduce in this moment.
But if you want, the Hartree
solution really leads to this.
It leads to a
Schrodinger equation
in which we are actually
trying to solve the problem
of a single electron at a time.
But that electron feels the
average electrostatic charge
distribution of all
the other electrons.
And one can actually
obtain this directly
from the variational principle.
That is, one can make an
answer for the wave function.
What is written here is this
most generic wave function.
And one can make what
turns out to be actually
a fairly severe approximation.
That is, we can say that this
many-body wave function can
actually be written as a product
of single particle orbitals.
So you see, what's happening,
when we are actually
making this hypothesis, is
that varying r1 will change
the amplitude of
the wave function
independently from what
happens to r2 and rn.
These have all become
independent variable.
There is no combined
effect what r2 and r1 are
doing-- so your any
couple, any triplet,
and so on and so forth.
So if you want, if we fix
all the other variables,
we can independently look at
what each one of these orbitals
is doing.
And you can think
just what would
come from a Taylor expansion.
This is an approximation.
It's not a true solution, OK?
Suppose that we were
dealing with two variables.
Well, I mean, something like--
think of a generic wave
function that could be written
as, say, the exponential of the
square root of r1 plus r2 that
can't be decoupled in the
product of two wave functions.
So the product of two
single-particle wave functions
is something simple
that doesn't capture
the complexity of all the
possible two-body wave
functions.
And so in this, it's
an approximation.
And so Hartree made
this approximation
and then asked
himself, what happens
if I actually throw
this approximation
in the variational principle?
Now, the difference
is that, instead
of having just a function that
varies parametrically, now what
we can really vary
in our valuational
principle are the shapes of all
these single-particle orbitals.
So what we are
asking ourselves is
a function of this
former throwing
into the variational
principle will give me
a condition that each of these
orbitals need to satisfy.
So if you want, you really
need to now calculate
with functional analysis what
are the differential equations
that each of these
orbitals, phi 1 to phi n,
needs to satisfy so that
the overall expectation
value of the energy is minimum
for a wave function written
in this restricted
class of product
of single-particle orbitals.
And so when you
actually work out
the fairly complex functional
analysis of this problem--
that's actually described,
if you're interested,
in one of the
references that we have
given you, the Bransden
and Joachain book
on the physics of
atoms and molecules--
what you obtain for
the specific case,
again of a Hamiltonian operator
in which the potential is given
by a linear combination of
attractive Coulombic potential,
is a set of equations.
That is, what you
obtain is a new set
of differential equations.
Instead of having, if you want,
one single Schrodinger equation
for a many-body wave function--
what you obtain if you are
dealing with n particles
is n different differential
equations, each one
being a differential equation
for only a single particle wave
function.
This is still fairly complex.
But the complexity
of this has gone
from being a complexity of a
wave function of 78 variables
to, say, the complexity
of 26 equations
in three variables
each, if we are
working in three dimensions.
And actualyl, the
form of this equation
is very intriguing
because this really
looks like a Schrodinger
equation for one electron.
You see, here is the
quantum kinetic energy
term for this electron.
And then there is
the interaction
between this single electron
with the Coulombic distribution
of nuclei.
And then there is a term--
you see, this appropriately
is called the Hartree term--
in which this electron, i, is
actually feeling a Coulombic
repulsion-- this is
the Coulombic term--
of a charge density
distribution.
Remember that if we take
this square model of a wave
function, we obtain the
probability of finding
an electron somewhere.
And the charge density is
nothing less than that.
It's the probability of
finding an electron somewhere.
And so you see, what we
have is, for the electron
that we have denoted as i, the
interaction between the wave
function and a potential, as
usual a potential, in which we
have the Coulombic term.
And the repulsion, the
Coulombic repulsion
is between the electron,
i, and the charged density
distribution of each and
every other electron, j.
So you see, this sum goes
over all the other electrons.
So my many-body
Schrodinger equation
has become a series
of equations that we
call single-particle equations,
a differential equation
for each and every electron.
And those differential
equations,
as I said, have been
obtained formally
just by applying this answer
to the variational principle,
are in the form of a
Schrodinger-like equation
with a kinetic energy,
an attractive potential.
And now, we have only a
mean field interaction
between the electrons
because electron i
doesn't instantaneously
need to know what each
and every other electron does.
But it actually only interacts
with the average charge density
distribution that is given
by the square model of j.
OK.
So this is a great
simplification.
And it actually allowed some
of the first calculations,
say, on atoms.
Actually, this was
developed in the late '20s.
And very quickly, it was
realized what was wrong.
And we'll see that in a moment.
That is the lack of
correlation because there
is a specific role that
electrons are fermions.
But really, this
was the first time
in which we had a workable
differential equation
for our many-body system.
And the most
important conclusion
of this, and where
the complexity
of the many-body
problem comes back in,
is that this new operator,
this new overall Hartree
operator acting on
the wave function,
has become, as we
say, self-consistent.
That is, the operator
itself depends
on what the other electrons do.
So it depends on
what the solution
to all the other
differential equations are.
So if you want to know
what electron i does
in the mean field of
all the other electrons,
you need to know what is
the wave function of each
and every other electron.
But in order to solve
the wave function of each
and every other
electron, you will
need to know also what
electron i is doing.
And so really, this
is very different.
The Hamiltonian operator
here is not anymore given
at the beginning of the
problem, but actually
needs to be found
because the operator--
the action on one
electron depends
on what the other electrons do.
And in order to find out
what the other electrons do,
we need to solve the set.
So this set of--
say, the case of iron again--
26 differential equations needs
to be solved simultaneously,
OK?
So we actually solve
it iteratively.
We start with a guess for what
the wave function would be.
And we try to find
a combined solution.
I'll describe in a moment
what the algorithm is.
So this is how the many-body
complexity comes in.
That is, we need to solve a
differential equation for which
we don't even know,
at the beginning, what
is the operator acting on our
single-particle wave function.
And so the concept
of self-consistency
and of iterative
solution will basically
be always present in all
the electronic structure
approaches that we are
going to see in this class.
And it's actually very
simple to figure out
what could be an
actual algorithm
to try to get to the solution.
That is, we need to start with
an arbitrary guess for all
those 26 orbitals.
And once we have
that arbitrary guess,
we can construct the charge
density of every electron.
And so we can construct what
would be the operator acting
on each one of the phi i.
That is, we can
construct this term here.
Once now we know what actually
our differential equation is,
we can solve it.
So we find what are the ground
states of each of those 26
differential equations.
And now, with those
ground states,
we can construct again
a charge density of each
and every single electron.
We put it together.
We have a new Hartree operator.
And we can solve these
differential equations again.
And we keep iterating
this until what
we obtain is a Hartree operator
in each differential equation
that doesn't change anymore.
And so we have now a set of
self-consistent orbitals.
In most cases, you actually
don't get to convergence.
So a lot of the
algorithmic advances
that has been done
in the 20th century
is actually to do
with this problem.
That is, we need to find
ways to get this procedure
to converge to an actually
self-consistent point.
But the concept is all here.
And if you want,
the simplest thing
that you can do to
make sure that you're
going to iterate
to self-consistence
is to move very slowly.
That is, whenever you
have a set of solutions,
you don't want to construct
your Hartree operator,
this new charge density,
with the solution.
But you want just to modify a
little bit your previous charge
densities to go in the direction
of the new charge density
that you were calculating.
So you somehow try to minimize
the change in the operators
from one iteration to the other.
And that tends to be actually
fairly functional in a lot
of problems.
Now, Hartree was a very
interesting character,
again growing up in Cambridge
at the turn of the century.
He became an expert in
differential equations
during the First World War
because basically people
had the problem of sending
cannonballs across the lines.
So there was a lot of
differential equations.
And so mid '20s, he
developed this general idea
of the Hartree equation
that really what we
call coupled
integral differential
equation because
there are derivatives
and there are integrals.
And so what you need
to do is now solve
this equation that can't
really be solved analytically.
And luckily, that
was the time in which
people were developing, if
you want, the first computers.
No electronic in
there-- so computing
machine, but mechanical.
And one of the first
computers was at MIT.
This is actually a picture
from the MIT archives.
There was an electrical
engineer named Vannevar Bush,
to which Building 13 the
Bush Building, is named
that developed one of the
first mechanical differential
equation solvers.
And so Hartree came at
the end of the '20s to MIT
to actually solve
the Hartree equation,
I guess, in some building
here exactly on that machine,
and then went back to Cambridge.
And so this, I thought,
was an interesting note.
So what do we obtain
when we actually
solve the Hartree equation?
Well, the most
fundamental concept
is that we are losing
some information
on what's happening
instantaneously
to all the electrons.
This is what we call,
generically speaking,
a correlation.
And I'll give you the technical
definition in a few slides.
But basically, this
is what's happening.
Let's consider the case
of the helium atom.
That is the simplest
case in which you
have more than one electron.
So what you have
is two electrons.
What does the Hartree
equation tell us about--
or what do the Hartree
equations tell us
about these two electrons?
Well, we have two equations.
And in each of
them, one electron
is going to feel an average
electrostatic repulsion
from the other electron.
So what we have is that
this right electron here
is attracted to
the nucleus and is
repelled by a spherically
symmetrical average charge
distribution.
So this is what's happening.
This is what Hartree tells us.
But in reality,
electrons instantaneously
try to keep themselves
as far apart as possible
because electrons
repel each other.
So in a simplified way, you
could think of electron 1
and electron 2 trying to orbit
the nucleus as much as possible
in a position of phases.
So the true two
interacting electrons
try to be as far as possible
at every moment in time
during their revolution
around the helium nucleus.
But this instantaneous
correlation--
that is, the fact that
the wave functions tries
to keep the electron as far
away as possible-- is lost
in the Hartree equations
because what we do is we
are really having one
electron interacting
with the average position
of the other electron.
And so in the Hartree
equation, there
are a lot of terms that have to
do with our initial electron,
red, being too close to
the green charge density
distribution.
So if you want, the
wave function-- that is,
the overall solution of
the Hartree equation--
tends to have too much
electrostatic repulsion
between electron
1 and electron 2.
And that's why ultimately the
energy of this Hartree function
is higher than
the true solution.
This is what is missing in
the Hartree equation, the fact
that what you want is
a lot of correlation.
That is, electrons want to
keep each other apart as
much as possible.
But that, if you want, is really
an instantaneous solution.
It's what people call
dynamical correlation.
Electrons want to keep
apart from each other.
But if you start
looking at a mean field
solution in which
only one interacts
with the average
charge density, you
have lost the
possibility of having
this instantaneous
non-symmetric distribution.
And so in general, this is
what we call correlation.
And this is what is missing
in the Hartree picture.
There is another set of very
fundamental concepts that
I'll describe in a moment
that the wave function--
the answer for the
Hartree wave function--
doesn't satisfy a fundamental
rule for wave functions.
We say it's not anti-symmetric.
And I'll show you in
a moment what it is.
That is, if you want,
it doesn't respect
a fundamental constraint
on the shape of functions.
And so that's, if
you want, an error.
And that's another source of
error in our final estimate
of the energy.
And in particular,
what it doesn't do--
it does not remove what is the
accidental degeneracy, the fact
that there is the same
energy for electrons that
have the same principle quantum
number n and the same angular
momentum number l.
But really, what
is most important
is this lack of a
physical constraint
and this lack of correlation.
Very soon, I mean
probably the same year
or a year later, Hartree,
and independently Fock,
realized that one could
actually find a better solution
to the problem
satisfying one, again,
of the fundamental
rules of nature that
had been discovered in the
'20s during the development
of quantum mechanics.
And so one of these
rules was what
is called the
spin-statistic correlation.
And this is really very general.
First of all,
there is a division
in elementary
particles that says
that all elementary
particles can be called
either fermions or bosons.
And so things like electrons
are actually fermions.
They have a half-integer spin.
But there is a
fundamental difference
between fermions and bosons.
And in particular, they satisfy
different statistical rules
for an ensemble of many
interacting electrons
or for many bosons.
And this rule-- so
this is nothing else
that-- again, another rule
like in classical mechanics--
you have Newton's
equation of motion.
In quantum mechanics,
you have a rule
that wave functions that
described fermions-- that
is, a wave function
that describes electrons
needs to have this
overall shape.
That is, it needs to change sign
when we invert two variables.
So we have this general
form for the wave function.
We exchange two variables.
And what needs to happen
is that the wave function
needs to change sign.
And this has something to do--
this can actually
be demonstrated.
But it's what people call
quantum field theory.
So it's an advanced concept.
But it's a very simple rule.
And it's a very simple symmetry
of the wave functioning.
In the same way, if you
want, you have in a crystal,
you have physical
symmetries for what
could be some of
your properties,
like an elastic tensor or a
piezoelectric coefficient.
Well, what you have is a
fundamental symmetry for a wave
function describing electrons.
It needs to change sign when
you invert two coordinates.
And so what the Hartree
solution didn't have
was exactly this
anti-symmetry requirement.
Remember, the Hartree
solution was just the product
of single-particle orbitals.
But Hartree very quickly
realized that you can actually
satisfy this
symmetry requirement
if instead of taking just
the product of n orbitals,
you take the sum of the
product of n orbitals
where you interchange
the variables in all
the possible ways--
putting a plus or
minus sign in front,
depending on how much
interchanges you had.
And I think it's very simple
to think of this problem if you
have, say, only two electrons.
So you have only two orbitals.
And so we could call these two
orbital, say, alpha and beta.
And so what we would have
is the Hartree solution
that is the product of the alpha
orbital function of the first r
variable and the
beta orbital function
of the second variable.
And this doesn't change sign
if we exchange 1 with 2.
It becomes a different function.
It doesn't become the same
function with the sign changed.
But you can see that what we can
do, without increasing really
the complexity of the problem--
that is, still dealing
with just the need of describing
two orbitals, what we could do
is take as an
ansatz for the wave
function describing two
electrons something that
is actually alpha 1 B2
minus B1 alpha 2, OK?
So we have still two orbitals
that we need to figure out.
We need to figure out
what is the shape of alpha
and what is the shape of beta.
But now, we are
using as an ansatz
for this two-electron
wave function
something that
actually changes sign
when you exchange 1 with 2.
So this is the trial
wave function of Hartree.
And this is the
trial wave function
of what we call the Hartree-Fock
method that is basically
a trial wave function that
has built-in anti-symmetry
constraint for
exchange of particles.
And this can be generalized
to the case of n particles.
And really, what we
call a sum of n terms
with all the possible
permutations,
signs, is nothing less
than a determinant.
If you think at what
a determinant is,
well, this determinant is
going to have one element.
It's going to have a sum
of terms that each of them
are rated as one term
from each column.
And we are taking all the
possible permutations.
And we are taking a plus
sign or a minus sign
in the sum of all
these terms, depending
on how many
permutations they are.
This is just the linear algebra
definition of a determinant.
And you see, again, a
determinant of two functions
is-- that's what I've
written here in green,
right here in the corner.
If we are asking what
alpha 1 determinant beta
1 beta 2 and alpha and alpha--
so beta 1 and alpha 2.
So this would be the specific
expression of this determinant
for the case of two particles.
And if you just solved
that determinant,
you have only these two terms.
So we haven't increased, in
going into the Hartree-Fock
method, the complexity
of the problem
that we need to solve because we
still need to find n functions,
where n is the
number of electrons.
And we need to find out the
appropriate differential
equation that descend from
the variational principle
once we stick this determinant
into the variational principle.
And again, it's not very
complex functional analysis.
And the Bransden Joachain
describes that in detail.
But with this new solution,
with this ansatz, what
we find is a new set of
differential equations
that look a lot like
the Hartree equation
that we had written before--
I'll go back to
this in a moment--
but have an additional term.
So what we find are, again,
single-particle equations.
So we have an integral
differential equation
for each single-particle orbital
lambda that is written in red.
And now, what we have is
a set of additional terms.
So we still have the
quantum kinetic energy
for that electron.
And we still have
the interaction
between that electron
and the collection
of attractive
Coulombic potentials.
We still have the Hartree
electrostatic term
in which the electron
lambda interacts
with the charge density
phi star mu times phi
mu of every other electron mu.
And I'll come to what goes
into this sum in a moment.
But basically, we
have electron lambda
interacting with the charge
density of electron mu.
And obviously, it's a Coulombic
electrostatic repulsion.
So there is a 1/r term.
But now, there is a new
term with a minus sign
that comes out only from the
anti-symmetry requirement.
And that is what is
called the exchange term
and is the new player in
the Hartree-Fock equation.
And it's a little bit
exotic because, if you want,
now we don't have any
more an operator that
could be, say, a local operator,
a charge density distribution
acting on an orbital.
But it's really become
a known local operator
because the orbital
on which I'm acting
has gone inside
the orbital sign.
So this new term here that
we call the exchange term is
a purely quantum mechanical
term that comes out exclusively
by the anti symmetry
requirements on what
happens to a fermionic
wave function
when we invert coefficients.
And there is another fundamental
distinction between the Hartree
and the Hartree-Fock equations.
This sum here-- you
see this time over mu--
in the Hartree
equation was running
over all the
electrons but the one
that we were considering, OK?
And now instead, this
sum mu is running
on all the possible electrons.
So what you have
in this term here
is what is technically
called self-interaction.
Suppose that for
a moment you were
trying to solve the hydrogen
atom with just one electron.
Well, what happens in
the Hartree equation
for the hydrogen atom--
there is obviously
no exchange term.
And there would be
also no Hartree term
because, in the Hartree equation
that you've seen before,
what you have is a sum over
all the other electrons.
But there are no
other electrons.
So this term is not there.
And what you
trivially recover is
the single-particle Schrodinger
equation for the hydrogen atom.
In the Hartree-Fock
equations, now even
for the hydrogen
atom, what you have
is that now you have this term.
You have actually an
unphysical self-interaction.
That is, you have electron
1 interacting with itself.
And that's really not
interacting with itself
in a local way.
But it's interacting with
its own charge distribution.
This is actually a sort
of unphysical thing.
But what happens exclusively
in the Hartree-Fock formulation
is that there is a second term.
There is the exchange term.
And the exchange term-- you
see, there is a minus sign--
cancels for the hydrogen atom
the self-interaction term
exactly.
If you just think-- if you
have only one electron,
you have that there
is only one phi.
So the lambda goes away.
The mu goes away.
So here, the electron
is interacting
with its charge distribution.
But then this term here--
just remove all the sum
and remove mu and lambda--
is canceled out thanks
to the minus sign
by the exchange term.
So Hartree-Fock
formalism is actually
what we call self-interaction
corrected, OK?
An electron, even if it's
a mean field picture,
doesn't interact with itself.
And that's actually a very
beautiful symmetry property
that other approaches like
density functional theory
do not satisfy.
And truly, a lot of the
problems that come out
in density functional theory
that otherwise perform really
well have to do with this
self-interaction problem.
And so those problems
are very significant,
if you think for a moment,
of problems like dissociation
of a molecule in atoms.
So when you really
consider how--
and we'll discuss
this in detail--
how the energy changes along a
process in which the electron
needs to localize itself
from a shared bonds
to a localized bond and that
self interaction problem
kills density function
theory and would actually not
be present to begin
with in Hartree-Fock.
So this is actually
very important.
There is another thing.
Actually, the
Hartree-Fock equation
has a beauty in the fact
that the operator acting
on the single-particle
orbitals does not
depend on which orbital you
are looking at because here we
have a sum over all the states.
So this does not depend on which
electron you are looking at.
That's different from
the Hartree equation.
In the Hartree
equation, there is
a Hartree term
where this sum would
exclude the electron itself.
So the Hartree
equations are actually
more complex to solve because
the operator changes depending
on which electron
it's acting on,
while the Hartree-Fock
equation has the same operator.
And so what we really
need to find out,
if we are solving
the iron atom, what
are the 26 lowest
energy solutions
for all the electrons in here.
So that's a very good thing.
But there are terms--
there are integrals
that are actually very
expensive still to calculate.
And ultimately, it's terms like
this that give us the scaling
cost of the equation.
Often, what we saw in such
a problem, we want to know
what is it scaling cost.
That is, how much
our calculation
becomes more expensive,
say, if we double
the size of the system
because that basically
tells us how large we can go.
And because of
these integrals that
involve three orbitals and the
fact that then to calculate
an energy of one more
sum, really the scaling
cost of the Hartree-Fock
equations, in principle,
goes as the fourth power.
So if I'm starting a
system with two electrons,
and then I want to study a
system with four electrons,
well, the cost has
gone up 16 times.
And a fourth power, like any
power, kills you very rapidly.
So that's why we can't study
a molecule like benzene
with Hartree-Fock.
But we can't study
really something
like DNA with Hartree-Fock
or really none
of the standard electronic
structure methods.
And a lot of effort that
goes into developing
a linear scaling
methods, that is methods
in which the computational
cost of your calculation
doubles if you double
the number of electrons.
And at the end, nature
is linear scaling
because really you can
imagine that the wave
function of the electrons
here doesn't have anything
to do with the wave function
of the electrons there.
So there is really,
when you go far away, no
exchange of information
between wave functions
in different parts of space.
And so there is ultimately
a linear scaling nature.
But our algorithms, in
general, are not yet there.
And we'll discuss a little bit
in some of the later classes
how to solve this problem.
Before going on, I wanted to
show one set of very simple
conclusions actually of having
a wave function with the proper
symmetry-- that is, having
a wave function written
as a Slater determinant--
because that form
gives us automatically
what is called the
Pauli principle.
If you remember what
the Pauli principle is,
it's that you can't have two
fermions-- two electrons,
in particular-- in the
same quantum state.
So you can't have two electrons
having, say, the same orbital.
And that's obvious
because, in a determinant,
two electrons having
the same orbital
would mean that two columns in
the determinant are identical.
And when two columns in a
determinant are identical,
the determinant
linearly dependent.
And so the solution is 0.
So a lot of good things
came out Hartree-Fock.
In particular, one could
start solving atoms.
And one would recover, say,
the shell structure of atoms.
So if you would obtain
the Hartree-Fock solution
for something like
an argon atom,
and then say plot the overall
charge density of the system,
well, it would start
to look like this as we
move from the center outwards.
So it would clearly
show the fundamentals
of the periodic table
nature of things.
That is, it would
show a 1s shell.
And then it would show
a 2s and a 2p shell.
And this is something that
some of the other approaches,
like the Thomas Fermi
approach that we'll
see in a moment that were
being developed at the time,
didn't have.
In general, Hartree-Fock
is very good
to describe atomic properties.
And what is most important is
a well-defined approximation
in the variational principle.
Remember, one of the
fundamental powers
of the variational
principle is that if we
make our wave function
ansatz, our [INAUDIBLE] wave
function more and more flexible,
we become better and better.
So Hartree-Fock is
a certain hypothesis
and gives us certain energies.
But what we can do is
make our wave functions
more and more flexible--
write them not only just
as a single determinant,
but a single determinant
plus something else.
And the solution that we'll find
will be computationally more
expensive to find, but
is going to be better.
So Hartree-Fock, in principle,
can be improved indefinitely.
That is something very
powerful conceptually.
It's practically very
complex because those
costs that we are
scaling already
in a simple Hartree-Fock,
like the fourth power,
keep going up.
What you will see in
this differential theory
is that besides
being a theory that
tends to give more
accurate results
for a lot of
physical properties,
it's something that also
scales a bit better.
It scales as the third
power of the size.
But it's a theory
that can't really be
improved in any systematic way.
One can find ingenious
ways to make it better.
But there isn't a brute
force improvement strategy
like there is in Hartree-Fock.
The Hartree-Fock operator
included the last term
that we have called
the exchange term.
And so for every possible atom,
for every possible molecule,
for every system, there is
a well-defined Hartree-Fock
energy.
And this Hartree-Fock energy is
going to be good, or very good,
or sort of so-so.
But it's always going to be
higher than the true ground
state energy of our system.
And actually, what
is technically
called the correlation
energy is the difference
between the true energy of your
system and the Hartree-Fock
energy.
So when people talk
about correlation energy,
they refer to all the
energy that is not captured
by a Hartree-Fock approach.
And in that sense, it's
a well-defined quantity.
Although, it involves a
generic term correlation
that can mean a lot of things.
And I'll show you
a few examples.
There is one more
thing that we can do.
We have never discussed
up to now spin.
But in reality, an
electron is described
by a wave function that
doesn't have only space parts.
So in order to
describe an electron,
we don't only describe what
the distribution of its wave
function is in
space, but we also
specify what is the
spin of the electron.
And that has to do
basically with spin
being an operator that can be
simultaneously diagonalized
with a set of--
well, it becomes complex.
But it's another quantity.
You can think of it as a color.
We need to specify if our
electron is red or blue.
Or in particular,
we need to specify
what is its spin, what is
its projection with respect
to an axis.
And so in this,
you need to think
of a wave function
of an electron
not having only a
spatial distribution.
But it has another property
besides the spatial variables
that is called the spin.
And you can make a
sort of approximation--
that is what is called a
restricted Hartree-Fock
scheme--
in which you decide
that an electron of spin
up and an electron
of spin down will
have the same spatial
part, so the same wave
function in space.
And their wave
function differs only
because you describe an
electron with spin up
and an electron with spin down.
Again, this corresponds to
the classical periodic table
picture.
You are constructing
the periodic table.
You go, say, from hydrogen--
one electron in the 1s level--
to helium-- one electron in
the 1s level with spin up
and another electron in the
same level with the spin down.
Actually, if you think,
the periodic table
itself is not a truth.
It's just a Hartree-Fock
picture of electrons, OK?
In principle, you shouldn't
be able to talk about
single-particle quantities--
1s, 2s quantities-- because,
in reality, if you have iron,
you have a many-body
wave function
that is an overall function
of all the electrons.
It's only when you enter
into a Hartree-Fock picture
that you can have a well-defined
concept as a single orbital
for an electron and what's
the energy for that electron.
So if you want, what we
think of this beautiful thing
as the periodic table is nothing
else than the Hartree-Fock
solution of the atoms.
And again, we can
make the approximation
in which we fill up every
orbital, every spatial part
with two electrons
with the same spin.
That tends to be a
very good approximation
for a lot of problems, say
a lot of bound systems.
And we'll see the case of the
hydrogen molecule in a moment.
But you could actually make your
wave function more flexible,
saying that say orbitals
don't need to be paired.
That is, an electron with a spin
up and an electron with a spin
down, even if they are
very close in energy,
can have two wave functions in
which the space part differs.
And this is really an ansatz
that contains this in itself.
So an unrestricted
Hartree-Fock solution
will always give
you a lower energy
than a restricted solution.
And we'll see in a
moment an example.
And this is the case of the
dissociation of a hydrogen
molecule.
So when we go back and try to
understand what is the bonding
between, say, two
hydrogen atoms--
and we had seen in one
of the first lectures,
we discussed about potentials--
that is, what is the energy
of a system as a function
of the nuclear distances.
And this is what
we are doing here.
We are trying to look at
the energy of the system
as a function of the
hydrogen-hydrogen distance.
And there will be an equilibrium
distance that corresponds
to the minimum of the energy.
And this is what classical
potential tried to do.
They tried to replicate
what is the energy
of a system as a function
of the nuclear coordinates.
And they tend to do very
well, as Professor Ceder has
told you, closer to the region
where they have been fitted.
If we have created a
potential around here,
we tend to be able to
reproduce things very well.
Obviously, it's very
easy to even find out
the potential that
reproduced all these curves.
But when you start to have more
than two atoms interacting,
there are all these problems of
bond-breaking and bond-forming
that can't really be given
by classical potential
and can be given by quantum
mechanical calculations.
And so in principle, we
have an ideal solution,
that is if we were able.
And nowadays, with
numerical accuracy,
we have basically been able
to solve almost perfectly
this problem.
We are able to find out
what is the total energy
of the system as a function
of the nuclear coordinates.
And then for this
specific problem,
the Coulombic potentials
at different distances,
we can find a
Hartree-Fock solution.
And with only two
electrons, we can
find a restricted
Hartree-Fock solution
in which we say, well,
these two electrons are
going to have the same orbital
part in the wave function.
They just differ in having a
spin up and spin down term.
And that makes them orthogonal.
So certain things are going to
happen in the exchange term.
But then we plotted this energy
as a function of the distance.
And this is what we have.
And then we can
release this condition.
We can say these
two electrons don't
need to have the same orbital
part for the wave functions.
They can have different parts.
And we can do that calculation.
And what we obtain is the
unrestricted Hartree-Fock
solution.
And you see two fundamental
things coming out from here.
First of all is that all
these Hartree-Fock approaches
give you an energy
that is obviously
larger than the exact energy.
It's the variational principle.
We can get lower and lower.
But we will never be able--
and that's very good--
to go below the true energy.
So the more flexible we
make our wave function
with both Hartree-Fock
methods, the more
we'll be able to recover
this last electron
volt of correlation energy.
So this is all where
our effort is going.
But you see,
Hartree-Fock is already
doing extremely well in giving
us the equilibrium distance.
I mean, this is the Hartree-Fock
equilibrium distance.
And this is the exact
So it's doing a good job.
What restricted Hartree-Fock
is not doing well
is giving us the
dissociation energy.
So restricted Hartree-Fock works
very well around the minimum.
Well, you really
should have this sort
of physical picture
of your ground
state being given by a bonding
combination of 1s orbitals.
Really, this is what the
covalent bond for a hydrogen
molecule is, is the two
1s orbitals covalently
overlapping.
And so restricted Hartree-Fock
does very well here.
And it's basically identical
to unrestricted Hartree-Fock.
But formally, unrestricted will
always be lower than restricted
because it contains the
restricted solution because,
in order to have a
restricted solution,
you just need to have the
orbital part for the two
electrons to be identical.
But because it can
also be different,
it will always be lower than
the restricted Hartree-Fock.
And you see, when we
break this system apart--
when we want to go from a bound
hydrogen molecule to two atoms,
the restricted Hartree-Fock
is doing very poorly.
You'll see, it'll
give us an energy
that is a very poor predictor
of the dissociation energy.
The dissociation energy-- the
true disassociation energy
of the system is the
distance between the minimum
here and the 0 value.
That this is, it's
the energy that we
need to spend to break
apart the molecule.
Unrestricted Hartree-Fock
will do very well.
I mean, obviously, it goes
to 0 in this scale when
we are far apart.
And so we have this 1
electron volt error.
But the restricted Hartree-Fock
is doing very poorly.
And why is that?
Well, basically because
the restricted Hartree-Fock
is really doubly occupying
the same spatial part
of the same bonding combination.
And that's good when
the system is bound.
But when you break
it apart, it's
very poor because what
you really want is--
in your solution, you want to
mix in another determinant that
is given by the
anti-bonding combination
because if you think
of the bonding state
as always a pile-up of
charge in between the atoms.
But when the molecule
disassociates,
you really want to have a
solution that has zero charge
density between the atoms.
And that looks much more like
the anti-bonding combination
of 1s orbitals.
And so the restricted
Hartree-Fock
doesn't have this freedom.
So it does it very poorly.
And unrestricted has
the freedom of having
two orbitals that are different
for the two electrons.
And so it just puts one orbital
on one atom and another orbital
in another atom instead of
having a single orbital doubly
occupied.
And so unrestricted Hartree-Fock
is going to be much better,
especially for problems like
the bond-breaking reactions
or for problems in which
you have isolated spins,
so you have atoms--
you have single electrons
that are not paired.
There are actually
a number of theorems
that can be derived from
the Hartree-Fock equation.
I won't dwell on them.
They are generically
called Koopmans' theorems.
And they have to do
with calculations, say,
of quantities like
the ionization energy
or the electron affinity.
What is the initiation energy?
It's the energy that you
need to spend to remove
an electron from an atom.
Or the electron
affinity is the energy
that you gain when an
electron captures--
sorry, when an atom
captures an extra electron.
So how do you calculate them,
say, in an electronic structure
calculation?
Say the ionization energy?
Well, it'll just be given
by the difference, say
for the case of iron
atoms, of the Hartree-Fock
solution with 26 electrons
and the Hartree-Fock
solution with 25 electrons.
So you do these
two calculations.
You take the difference.
And that will be our
ionization energy.
And the affinity will
be the difference
between the calculation
with 27 or 26 electrons.
But you can actually
do very well
without having to
do two calculations,
but having just one calculation,
if you make the hypothesis
that really your
single-particle electrons do not
change in the process.
So if you make the
hypothesis that
in going from 26 to 25 the
shape of electron 1, electron 2,
electron 3 do not change--
and that's an approximation.
They will change a little bit.
But if you make
this approximation,
you can actually prove
that the difference
between the system
with 26 electrons
and the system
with 25 electrons--
the difference in
energy is just given
by the eigenvalue of
the 26th electron.
So basically, a
single calculation
gives you already an estimate
of ionization energies
and electron affinities.
Although, in principle,
you could always
do two calculations.
But these, if you find them, are
called the Koopmans' theorems.
What is missing in Hartree-Fock?
What is this correlation that
we are trying to recover?
Well, often we think
at it in two ways.
We can think that part of
it is dynamical correlation.
It's what I described to you
in the case of the helium atom.
That is, when we have two
electrons interacting,
they like to keep each other
as far away as possible
from each other instantaneously.
And because we have a
mean field solution,
we are actually overestimating
the Hartree energy.
We tend to put electrons
too close to each other
because we have one
electron interacting
with the average
field of the other.
And so in that
energy term, you have
that there are a lot
of configurations
in which the electrons are
too close to each other.
That raises the
energy of your system.
So we call that
dynamical correlation.
And these are heuristic terms.
And then there is
another class of errors
that we are making that often
are called static correlations.
And those have to do
more with the fact
that a single determinant
solution doesn't have
the flexibility that you need.
And this was the case of the
breaking apart of the hydrogen
molecule.
You really want, when you you're
breaking apart a molecule,
to have a two determinant
kind of flexibility
with both bonding and
anti-bonding combinations.
And all of this is missing.
And we can systematically
build it up,
improving, say, the flexibility
of the wave function.
And one of the
conceptually simplest way,
but computationally
more expensive ways,
is actually to look
at the wave function
that now, instead of being
given by a single determinant,
is given by a combination
of determinants
with different coefficients in
which, say, the determinants
have been constructed with
a number of orbitals that
include also excited orbitals.
Our original Hartree-Fock
determinant, say,
for iron was given by
the 26th lowest solution.
And this is it.
But then you could
add a second term
that contains 25 of those 26
lower solutions and then one
excited state.
Or you could do a
number of things.
But basically, you could
increase the variation
of flexibility of your problem.
And the more
flexible you become,
the closer you get to
the right solution.
But you pay an enormous
price for this.
And this general
approach would be called
configuration interaction.
That has actually this horrific
scaling of n to the 7th.
And so you can really
do it for 10 electrons.
But you can't do it for
11 electrons on your best
computer.
Probably now, we can get
to 15 electrons or so.
And I think with
this, I'll conclude.
So this was a panorama
on Hartree-Fock methods.
One of the best books
is the Jensen book
of computational chemistry
in the literature.
And then with the
next class, we'll
start looking at density
functional theory and again
the Nobel Prize for
chemistry in 1998.
Next Tuesday is-- being
Monday Presidents' Day,
we'll have on Tuesday
Monday's schedule of classes.
That means, in practice,
that we have no class.
So you have time until
Thursday of next week
to brood over this.
I've posted a few
readings on the website.
If you are really
wanting to more
about the functional theory,
one of those readings
is the Kohanoff
paper on fundamentals
of density financial theory.
And if you want to know
more of Hartree-Fock,
we won't really see any more
in the rest of the class.
You should go to one
of the references.
And otherwise, see
you next Thursday.